hey y'all it's under couch here in this
tuesday video we're gonna be going over
the tidy verse so i've made videos going
over basically
all of the main ideas of tidy models but
i never actually made a video on the
tidy verse
so i'm actually trying to be a little
bit more active in the youtube community
by posting on the community tab um so i
posted a poll
just asking you guys what you guys
wanted to see and many of you guys
wanted to see
basically a high-level overview of
basically the main functions
of each uh package from the tidyburst uh
so i think that'd be pretty useful for a
lot of beginners
um and maybe for a lot of intermediate
people too
so this is gonna be a three-part series
for the tiger verse uh i'm gonna go over
first uh the main packages which is
tidy r and d plier
um but then i'll probably make one on
like per and maybe a final one on like
four cats
stringer and reader because those three
packages kind of uh
they're kind of uh just use uh offhand
usually
so um let's actually kind of do a high
level overview of tidy r
and d plier so tidy r
is basically trying to tidy
our data our data frames and we're
trying to convert it to a tidy format
where every column is a variable every
row is an observation
every cell is a single value and one
thing that i would say about tidy r is
it's basically about
manipulating the data um from a
dimension standpoint
and not from the actual um values itself
so you know we're doing a lot of like uh
converting
all of our columns to into tight formats
or doing a lot of uh
rearranging or reshaping um whereas
dplyr
is all about you know making new columns
um
you know using group buys summarizing
stuff and and doing
most of the actual like feature
engineering and computation
so obviously tidy r d player go hand in
hand together
um and they're very useful but tidy r is
mostly for
you know manipulating the data as a
whole whereas deep pliers mostly about
manipulating the data individually
um this video is actually gonna be
pretty um ad hoc and improv
um just because i think this this be an
interesting format to kind of go over
um i will just go over the main
functions
and i think the first thing we're going
to do is actually stick with tidy r
and when we actually look at tidy r
we can see that there's not a lot of
functions you know the main functions
we're actually using
uh is the pivoting and maybe
uh the character vectors and the missing
values but other than that
it's really mostly pivoting so let's
actually go over
pivoting first i'm going to go on to
season two of the title tuesday repo
i'm going to open up a our markdown file
and i'm going to call this tidy tuesday
uh tidy r and d pi your
sweet
so we really just need the tidy verse
okay and what's cool about
these uh packages is that they actually
include
some data so i'm actually just gonna
load in um one of the data sets which
i've actually never seen but we can do
billboard okay
um billboard and billboard is a perfect
example of a data set we would see
in real life um and that we would
probably want to manipulate
right as the qb we have a super wide
data set um this is something you would
see in excel you know where we have like
our dates as our columns
um and then our values so let's actually
go
over um pivoting which is basically the
main thing
um with a tidy r
so tidy art uh is all about the actual
data manipulation or data um
reshaping and not actually changing the
values so
when we go to billboard let's actually
go and see what we
want from this um so
just what we would think about is so
this is i guess the
um the rs and the song the date entered
and then the weekly values
i think maybe just like uh i guess
when we actually look at this thing song
so song rankings for the top 100
in year 2000
okay so what we would actually want is
basically having a weak column
with a weak number and then the actual
value so we can actually do that pretty
easily
by using a pivot longer
so a pivot longer actually uh specifies
um a few things we wanted to base select
our names and our values
so what we want right now is we want to
convert all of these columns
into basically a long format so we can
actually do that by just saying
one we can just select wk one two
uh was it
wk 76 right
and now we have our names and our value
um and in this case we can actually
change it to like
names to oh names
names two week and then we'll say values
to equals rank
so now we have that i mean what it's
actually doing is just converting all
this
right and basically you know pivoting it
um down to a single uh i guess like
column value
on the structure like that
okay so also with pivot longer
we can see we have like names too which
is the specifying the actual column
names that we're going to define for
that week
or for that column and we have values
too which will basically design the
you know these values and what we want
to call its
right so these would be the names these
would be the values
um additionally what we would want to
look at for our pivot longer
is sometimes we want to fill in our
values right
so we can also do
if we go back to our pivot longer we can
convert this right back
into our regular set so pivot wider
and in this case with pivot wider we're
taking essentially the opposite where
we're trying to say
where we want to be our column names
which is this
this column here weeks and what do we
want our values for each column
which would be the rank so if we do
pivot wider and said
names from we can say week and then
values from
is rank and as you can see it's the same
thing as our
original billboard data sets one thing
that we can do though
is when we pivot wider we can also do a
values
fill and we could do like you know maybe
a minus 999.
uh oops pivot water values fill
uh
fill um list
minus 999
uh and then oh
oh yeah that's why if we do a drop in a
which will essentially remove all that
um since we actually have values already
as nas
if we do that we can see that we will
replace the nas as minus 999
which is common way to say that you know
we have missing values or it's not there
so that's basically pivot longer pivot
wider um it's definitely very useful
um one thing i would say is like um i
use
pivot wider a lot to just do like one
hot encodings
so if i want to say select uh artist
and track and then maybe like date
and then we'll just do that
artist so if i want to say
i'm just going to count the artist right
now okay
so a lot of times when i'm working with
data i want to do some type of one-hot
encoding
um so often i'll just do a mutate which
i'm going to add a column and say n
equals one
and then i'll just do a pivot wider and
i'll say
names from um i guess like uh artist
values from is n and values fill
is zero and that way i can create
essentially like a one hot encoded
data frame right so baby don't cry it's
a one because tupac uh
uh wrote or produced the song right
and you always do like a values fill
equals zero because it'll be a lot of
it'll just be n a's if we don't
right um so i just do a values fill
is equal to zero and that allows me to
do
is create a one hot encoded vector um
often times it's pretty useful
um especially if we do like chemidal
functions or do a
some more complex um network analysis um
using pivot wider is very useful
for that type of stuff so one
another thing that's kind of interesting
about the tidy r package
right is we actually have a few
um a few uh
functions that are useful with other
packages
so for example the nest function is very
useful for
other packages which can get a little
bit complicated but
what we can essentially do is create
a a a table as our value
and what's interesting about nest is
that we can kind of create a
a data frame with nested data frames
so if i say minus artist which i'm
saying i'm going to nest everything by
artist
we can see that for each artist uh we
have
the data everything besides artists so
in this case would be
track date entered week etc as
its own little data frame and that can
be useful
say with the per package or if we want
to do
you know some type of function that
applies for each group
um i'm definitely going to touch more on
this when we get into
the per package but it is very useful
but i don't think we'll kind of
we're not gonna dive too deep into it uh
for this video
especially since we still have deep fire
left
um let me look at the actual other
functions in
um tidy r one thing i will say about you
know just overall using the uh
tidy verse is you kind of don't have to
think too much about
you know which function comes from which
package unless you're doing a lot of
like package development
but if you're watching this video and
you're beginner uh it's something you
really don't need to worry about
right now so uh all these functions that
i'm i'm referencing saying that you know
this function for tidyr
this functions for d plier et cetera uh
you don't really need to worry about
that right now because as long as you
load in
the tidy verse they'll always be
available for you
okay um oh yeah so
one last very useful uh
function i guess two two useful
functions right now
is the drop n a um which is good it just
drops any samples
uh that are that contain missing values
i think that's pretty self-explanatory
so i don't want to go too into it
but one of the more useful um
uh functions from the tidal yard package
is the separate rows
uh function so if we do separate uh
rows it'll basically separate a
value um and put that into another row
so let me actually find a better data
set for this just so i'm gonna
go back here and see if i can find a
cool data set maybe uh
um maybe
construction let's see that let's see if
that works
okay construction
now let's see uh maybe fish
encounters uh
no okay i wanna
smith no
religious income
no i just said uh let's see here
and we can we can go back and just do
billboard it's not too big of a deal
i'm actually gonna count the artist
first just to make sure we
add um do we have any ands
hmm let's see here trying to find a
a good example of a data set okay i
guess i don't have any
okay well that's not that big of a deal
okay
so one thing that we can do right is use
these separate
rows and what we basically say is
we'll specify the column that we want
and the separation
so in this case i guess we just do like
a comma
and it'll actually separate the rows
it'll basically copy that entire row
and separate it and split it into two um
identical rows but it'll split it based
off the column so
for example atoms yolanda
we can see atoms is now split and we can
also see there's a yolanda right there
um and that's that's extremely useful
okay so that's basically it for the tidy
tidy r
um what we're now going to go into deep
wire which is definitely the medium
potatoes
um this is the this is the stuff that to
be honest if you actually know d player
very well
um you can you probably land any analyst
job
to do data analysis because this is
where all the data
munging and all the data cleaning and
the data manipulation goes through
is d plier okay
so now let's actually go into dplyr um
when we write d fire
okay um let's see what what does should
we use from deep wire
um band members is that a good day set
maybe okay let's try it let's try out
band members
or band instruments uh no can
members okay well
you want we'll just do the iris data
side okay so
the main we're going to first go over
um data
called column creation data manipulation
first okay
so if we actually go back to dplyr
um we can see that you know one table
verbs or you know
uh things that we're gonna apply to a
data frame arrange
we're gonna sort we're just gonna sort
it by values uh count we're just going
to count values
distinct which will you know just remove
any duplicates
filter mutate pull relocate
okay so these things pull relocate
rename
i'm not totally um
nested i mean it's not totally necessary
for what we want to do
uh so it will first go over the actual
um
select so first i'm you if you've
noticed i'm always using these things
which are called pipes uh and this is
basically the same thing as saying
um mutate you know giving it the iris
giving it the data and then saying like
i don't know uh
tess is equal to uh t
right so instead of me having to write
in iris over here i can just write iris
pipe mutate test is equal to t
and they're the same thing i prefer
using pipes but if you don't want to use
pipes
just do this as is one of the ways to
really unders
to really get a good intuition of the
pipe function is just to use pipe as
and then so i take iris and then i
mutate by adding test
etc okay
so the iris dataset is pretty popular to
use and i think it's going to be a
pretty good data set to use when we're
teaching
mutate so mutate
is the main function we're going to use
to create any type of column or to do
any type of feature
um manipulation
so if we say mutate we can kind of
create our features so we can say
you know let's create a square root
sequel right so then we can say square
root
of simple dot length
and we created that okay
um i think the mutate function is pretty
uh straightforward you're essentially
just creating a new column
um referencing other columns um you can
also do if else statements in it so
we'll say uh
uh i don't know larger than then
five is equal to and in this case we're
just say if
else which is a
also which is also a d player verb um
instead of using the base if else we can
just use on the d player bells where we
set a condition so
simple dot length is
greater than 5 then greater than 5
else
less than uh or we'll always say not
greater than five
not greater than five right and there we
have that
um again mutate is pretty
straightforward but once you start going
into like group buys
um then we'll start seeing how things
can change real quick
so right now since we have mutate one
another function that i use
pretty much every day is the count
function
um so the count does what we wanted to
do which is
count a specific thing so in this case
let's just count species
uh it'll count it as you can see we have
50
um samples for each species
what's also interesting about count is
that we can do an
add count uh which will just add
the count of the species so
count species and we see at 50 right
there instead of just removing
all of our values so add count we'll
just add the account
and just keep all of the uh the data
and then if we just do count it'll
essentially just group it by what we're
counting and just show that value
so what's also kind of cool about count
is we can kind of use it as almost a
a count and do like a pairwise count or
a grouped count so in this case since we
have larger than five
we might be curious you know let's count
the species
and that uh that are also larger than
five so let's count these two groups
and we can see right here like okay so
ptosis you know basically even
for greater than five and not greater
than five versus color
most of them are greater than five
virginica mostly greater than five
okay uh and let's actually do some uh
some tidy are too so in this case what
we want to do is maybe just do a pivot
wider
and in this case we can kind of decide
you know do you want just
you know uh our species for our rows and
then
you know the count larger than five and
less than five over here or do we want
to switch it
you know if you want to send it to
someone so let's just first do uh
our names from larger than five and then
our values from
n right so now we kind of have a little
um was it a a margin table or something
uh all right it's like a cross table of
it so we have like setosa
we can see you know which ones have are
greater than five which ones are not
greater than five
um and then we can also switch it if you
want
or it's right here um so we can see okay
out of all of them
which were greater than five you can see
that's not greater than five
in this case it'd probably be better
just to do arson five right here
i'm just if you're gonna show it to
someone cool
uh so that's basically count um there's
a few other things that we can say
um with count we can also specify
uh sort which equals to
true so our results can just be already
sorted
um which is pretty useful um
additionally what we can do
is we can all say dot uh name
or was it name and we can specify
instead of
n and we say like you know freak right
or
or maybe count so you can also specify
the column name of that of the account
of the uh results instead of just the
default value the default name is
n so yeah um mutant and count
um definitely one of the more useful
functions uh in the
indie player and and they're the
functions that you're gonna use the most
um out of everything okay
so now let's actually go into i guess
filtering
um again filtering i think is still
pretty self-explanatory
but we can just say filter and then we
just specify
our conditions so we can say like
species
is equal to you know setosa
so um with r we do the double equal sign
or we want to say not equal we can say
not equal
um we can also say maybe in
right in and just give it a list using
the little c
thing so let's just say setosa and
versicolor yep versus color
right so right here we can and then
right here we can see that we
in you know we're just filtering um
the species by a list using an in
in filter right
um we can also specify different things
like
species is equal to setosa
or say sepal length is greater than five
um stuff like that so again with the
filtering i think
it's pretty self-explanatory um you kind
of have to remember how to do the
species
uh i don't know how to do the the
filtering syntax so you can say
equals or greater than like greater than
equal to
less than or equal to uh
not equal to um we can also get
a little bit crazier with our our
filtering and say
um we could say oh we might have two
conditions and either condition just
needs to be
satisfied so in this case we'll use
parentheses and say
this the species has to be like setosa
and let's say like the sepal length
has to be less than five or
this species is equal to
i don't know where's the verse versa
color
and the petal length let's say petal
length has to be greater than one right
so that way we we can have like two
different um
filtering criterias uh and and one of
them has to be satisfied and within
these
filtering criterias both both criterias
have to be satisfied for that one
um little filtering okay
so that's basic filtering that's basic
manipulation that's basic counting
um i guess we can do selects i i i think
again these things are pretty
self-explanatory you just select it you
just so that's how what you want to do
right um you can also do like a little
list so you can say select
say seepal.link to pedal.link
right um i i guess i could go to like uh
was it
the tidy selectors but i think i'm gonna
actually include that into
my second video on uh four cats
uh stringer and stuff and reader i think
that'd be a pretty um
uh good video because that's basically
like the miscellaneous packages that are
just one-off functions that are useful
um so yeah that's that's basically how
you can do it you can also assess like
everything but so say minus
simple.length and for me
i that's how i basically remove columns
if i if i don't find it useful
um there are other functions i can
basically say like you mutate it and it
just drops whatever you're using
but for me i like to just kind of have
everything in place
and if i don't want it i can explicitly
say i don't want it by either doing the
minus
or selecting everything but uh so yeah
those are the select functions
that's too crazy
okay so now we're actually gonna get
we're gonna get into
uh the in into uh
i guess we can get into let's see here
sorry about that
um trying to read read these um
functions
yeah let's let's get into uh
um the group by and the summarize
function
so the group by if you have sql
experience is very
is the same thing as kind of a sql group
by um
so when we say group by you can kind of
think of it as having
essentially um data
for each group that are individual
so when we specify a group by it means
we're essentially looking at our data
frame like this
where you know setosa's sepal length and
c
petal like cytosis data or any any rose
that contains setosa
will not be included in say the
versacolor group or the virginica
group so what's cool about
um species with group by is generally
you do a summarize
and then we can compute basically like
group level
um data group level computation so in
this case i want to find
say i don't know the the average c
sequel length so we'll say average
sequel length is equal to
mean simple dot length
cool so we have the average seat bowling
and stuff like that
um but what what if we actually don't
want to do that you know what if we want
to use this average simple length
on a group level basis um but we want to
keep all the rest of stuff you know we
can also do the dot drop
equals false but what i usually do
right is i'll just say group by
and then let's say mutate um average
simple
length and then then i'll just do mean
dot sequal
length and then we can see it just adds
it right there and this has repeats for
it for each species
and this is the way i prefer it but you
can also uh do the was it the dot drops
equal
false but to be honest i don't really
like the uh
the the way that people do that um
just because uh i think it's not really
that common to see i think this is a
little bit more
self-explanatory that way we can have
like summarize
doing you know we return only those
values
whereas mutate we kind of just return
everything right
so why would you want to use a group by
um because if we actually don't do it
a group by
with our average we can see
that our values are different right
because
in this case since we're grouping by
species it's taking the species
group and find the average and then
basically joining it for each row that
has that specific species
whereas if we don't do a group by it
contains the entire
data frames average which can still be
useful
right if you're in this case you know
what if i wanted to compute
um the average sepal length and then
also compare it to
um average length compared to the
average
sequel link right we can kind of have
that right there
and we can see how you know the average
simple length changes with the species
but the average length doesn't
um and then you can obviously see how
the sepal length is constantly changing
for each row
so yeah that's pretty useful um
another thing with i guess group by and
summarize
so if let's say we can just say
summarize and we'll say average
you know length is mean simple
dot length you know oftentimes when
we're finding averages
uh it's useful to find also the count
of those those uh the the the
observations for that group
um so we can't use counts but we can use
is
n so we'll say like uh observations is
equal to
n and this will basically count the
actual samples
or the observations we have for that
group so n is a common thing
to do uh with that type of stuff
okay um i think that's basically it for
the group i can summarize i think
they're pretty straightforward
uh you can get pretty complex when
you're using like nested data so
let's actually no i'm not gonna do that
uh we'll do that into our mapping things
um but oftentimes you can use summarize
uh with
other things like linear models and
stuff like that
um but i think that'll be definitely
more of a uh
a per package video so we're not gonna
go over that yet
um okay so what i'm looking at here
um we can see this i don't think uh we
can
um let's see here okay we can just let's
go over
these things maybe
um yeah we'll go over this so
there's a few other um pretty useful
data manipulation functions
um that i started using so one of the
things that we can do is the case
one statement okay
and one of the things that i think if
you're working with excel
when you actually have to do a lot of if
else statements it gets very confusing
very quick
um so a lot of times if especially if
you're coming from sql you're like
well we should just do a bunch of case
statements and uh
our our deployer has case statements so
let's actually do that so let's just say
um
i don't know maybe like a test is equal
to case one
and case one we can just have multiple
arguments so we can say
if say simple dot length is greater than
five and i don't know simple.with
is greater than three then we'll say you
know large
um in this case we have our little
condition we use this little tilde to
specify
that we're kind of ending our our
condition
into the actual output um then we can
specify another condition
um in this case we'll just say
simple.length
we'll say sql.length
i don't know is greater than
i don't actually we'll say yeah was is
less than
i don't know four and c
pull dot width is less than
two and we'll say small
and lastly for our i guess our base case
our end case we can just say
t and then we'll specify the last thing
or the default value
if they don't aim those conditions which
will say like
medium right
so we can see that how it has all this
thing
and what's useful about this is if we
were to do this
with an if else statement it could look
pretty
weird i'm really quick so if we say if
else
we'll just say uh sepal length is
greater than three
then large else it'd be an if else
and then we'll say like
uh then it'd be like small and then be
like medium
so as you can see right it it gets kind
of
kind of messy
right so we can see how this is much
cleaner than this
okay um let's actually go over i guess
window functions so i actually find
myself using a bunch of window functions
in my own work
especially when you're working with a
lot of time series data so i think
with the we have econ right economics or
yeah
economics um one of the things that we
can do
is one we can say you know what's
let's actually i don't know we'll select
date and uh
unemployment first
so with window functions it's always
about kind of going through the rows
sequentially and stuff like that so what
we can do first is
one of the things we might want to do
specifically for like forecasting is
you know we might want to use uh
i don't know um like get the previous
month so we'll just say
new tape and we'll say previous
unemployment and we can say is equal to
and then we can use the uh lag function
lag
and in this case we specify what column
we want to lag which is unemployed
uh we can specify how many um periods
which we'll just say that was it the
previous month
and then we also say in order by oops
and we say date because that's the thing
we're trying to arrange it by
right and we can see here you know for
1967 we had 2944
and then in august we have 29 45 and
then previous unemployment
is the lagged or the previous month and
obviously with the previous and uh with
the default
is going to be an n a because we don't
have any um 1967
and 0.601 but we also like default is
maybe
you know like i don't know the mean of
unemployment
which is not smart right because it
should be increasing so
we might just say uh
unemployment right right there or we
just drop it
so that's basically a lag function we go
we can also do a lead function
which instead of taking the previous
it's taking the next
uh the next uh value ahead of it
which is pretty useful too so in in this
case
um we we kind of just don't really need
to worry about that in fact we can
actually pop this out
uh
axial date and maybe we can just say gm
line
uh aes y equals on uh on it and
boy
right so we can see you know obviously
it's going to match pretty well with the
monthly unemployment as a forecast
because it's just logged okay
so that's basically a basic window
function
um now let's actually go into
um i guess we can go into the uh
what was it ranking and uh ranking
uh so these things are pretty useful
um so you can do row number and tile
main ranked dense rank percent rank
chemo distribution
stuff like that just so you can get an
understanding
of you know the the relative proportion
of your
data of the values in your data set um
so in this case you're like okay let's
say we have all these samples
and we want to say you know yeah we have
reciprolink but
maybe we want to get our steeple length
like rank
so let's say uh s length
rank and we say you know on one hand we
can just say
our row number or our end tile so we can
say
uh row number
right but if we want to do a row number
um we might have to
you know just arrange our sequel length
right so this is like oh and we have to
do it in descending order
so to specify descending order just type
in desc
so right there we you know this is our
our largest value 7.7
is our second largest value but since
we're doing row number
um it kind of just treats ties as it
doesn't treat ties at all
um which you know we might want to we
might want to do something about that
um so what's actually going to
entile um which i i actually don't use
intel that much so let's see what it
does
yeah it doesn't do that um because i
think you have to specify
oh what is it what is it
entile is a uh where is it
entire is a rough ring which breaks it
into n bucket okay into buckets
so we we probably wouldn't want to do
that so if you want to do six
so right there we split it into six
different buckets um i don't really use
this very often i generally just do
you know chemo distribution or something
like that so let's actually go to
you know um dense rank
um which will be that
and as you can see right here they share
the same rank
um which is i think the most useful
thing uh you can also do chemo
distribution
uh cumulative distribution right and
it's the same thing but it's in it's
normalized between zero and one
um which is pretty useful too um if you
want to do a very rough estimate
of ranking something instead of just
estimating the distribution you just get
your cumulative distribution
so those are basically the more useful
things one of the things i also
find i do often is um
you know say you're working with this
data set and you say well i want to
select you know the samples that have
the the longest sepal length right
so you could just say arrange
by c bolt like descending seep folder
length and then you can say i don't know
maybe like a head
and we'll select the first six rows
but another way um
is you use the slice function so with
slice you can say slice and say 1 to
6 which is essentially the head function
but we also have more things now such as
slice
max so in this case we want to say like
see
we want to select i don't know the first
five
um oops size max
slice max right here right
um which will select the max value
um sometimes you might want to choose
the smallest one which should be slice
min um and that's pretty useful
for me i i generally will do a filter
so i'll just say like iris
filter uh rank i'll say like uh i don't
know
uh what what kind of rank should i do
um i'll just do like i don't usually
actually accumulate distribution so i
say like human disk
uh sibo length and i'll say greater than
like you know 0.95
or greater than equal to 0.95 and i'll
select that
right or you can also do obviously one
of the
other ranking functions so i can go to
dense rank
is greater than five right or actually
um yeah or is
is less than five and that'll that'll do
the uh
um the minimum one but we also do was it
that
and descending order which will do the
kind of inverse of the rank for me
if i want to do uh you know maybe the
top five
um i there there are different ways to
do it too um but in this case you know
this
is kind of how i would do it too uh how
i would do it you know from more of a
programmatic standpoint
but there are other ways where you can
say like if you know you don't have any
um if you don't have any uh duplicates
you're gonna say like slice
you know one through five right
so same thing uh it's not really that
same thing but like this is a quick and
dirty way to do it
um where you're not really accounting
for you know any uh
any uh any duplicates you can also use
the dense rank which is more
programmatic
or you can just say like i want to slice
the the minimum or the maximum
and call it a day okay
so i want to look back on deepwire and
see if i
have any other functions that i should
really go into
and i think basically what i should be
doing now
is yeah
is uh the two table verbs so this will
probably be the last part of this
video um which is probably this is
probably the most important thing to
kind of go into
is oftentimes you're working with
multiple data sets and you want to join
them together
okay um let's see let's see what they're
actually using for their
further examples and kind of go over it
yep okay band members
so band members
uh john okay and
instruments
what does inspirations to look like
okay
instruments and then entrance two
are they the oh they're the
they're basically the same thing okay
okay so in this case
you know this is kind of like a very
small table obviously
and you could probably manually write it
into excel and do it yourself
uh with some like index matching but in
this case um
we would probably want to join you know
our band members instruments
to our band members so if we look at our
band members
right we have mick from the stones
john uh from the beatles and paul from
the beatles
and we would want to join our
instruments to our band members
so we can do what we can do is we can do
a simple join
in this case we want to put our band
instance right here
um and since technically they're 101 we
can just do an inner join
but i i'm probably just going to do a
left join
so left join and we just specify
the thing we want to join so band
members and band instruments
uh and then we can specify what we want
to join by
and since band members is the first
thing we're using which is like the
first or the left table and band
instruments is a the right table you
want to specify
the first person or first tables
uh column that we want to specif uh join
with so name
and then we're going to join band
instruments 2
using the bn instruments calm artist so
artist and we have that
oh okay and mick isn't there
so one thing we can also do is sometimes
we can get away with not specifying it
but usually it'll actually want you to
do it so if we actually say
so uh canon instruments
band instruments where we can see how
band band members and band instruments
has the same
name that we want to join on they'll
just automatically do it
but generally it's better it's good
practice to specify
um directly or manually the the way you
want to join it
okay so i'm actually going to create a
table
um because these these examples are not
great so i'm going to say table
and we'll say uh x is equal to
c one two three y equals c
two 3 4 z equals
4 5 6.
oh what
oh there's no c okay
okay um in this case
i'm actually going to create another
table so tibble and let's just say uh
i don't know we'll just copy this
actually we'll say
df and we'll say df2
is df and then say mutate x is equal to
x plus one okay
ef and then df2 so let's say with
df right here we want to just join these
tables together
and we want to just join or we only want
to uh
have left are the things that are
matched up perfectly together
and now i think about it i should
actually not do this um sorry about this
so we'll just say x and we'll say a
and b right okay
so we have df and df2
and we want to join them by say x
so in this case we can just do a simple
inner join
by div two and we specify x
and it joins all of this stuff together
no problem because we have
um df which is x y and z
and then df2 which is x a and b
and x have the same values and they join
them perfectly together
you know what if we actually want to do
some type of filtering
so another common thing is like we'll
say filtered
data and we'll just say like um
you know we we did an analysis and we're
like okay well we want to filter
you know um filter where
z is greater than greater than or equal
to five
right greater than or equal to five
but we want to actually use this as like
some type of join
um so we what we can do is with df2
and df we can see here like okay
um one common thing that i guess i run
into is
i have these values that i essentially
want to remove
so actually i'm going to say less than
five
so like any any values that are less
than five i don't want in my actual
um data frame so what we can also do is
an anti-join
and this will just remove
anything shared between these two values
these two tables so if we go into like
tidy text
often anti-joins are used to remove any
stop words
because we have like a list of words
that we want to remove so it kind of
finds all the rows that have that word
and just removes it out
so anti-join the inner join kind of do
similar things except they do the
opposite of it so inner join will keep
all the matches anti-join remove any of
the matches
okay um let's see here what do i i want
to go back here and see if there's
anything else that we need to do
uh nest join or i definitely don't use
that at all
um let's see here
oh yeah we can do uh yeah union and set
diffs
are probably union and minus i think
i accept if yep
okay so these i what are they called a
compound or compound complementary
queries
um basically if we have say um
say we have a um df
and then okay how am i gonna do this
actually we'll just use iris because the
the df example is kind of confusing so
let's say that we have um two tables so
let's just say iris
and iris uh whatever's three oh
we have the iris table and then i think
this thing's
okay
and i'll slice one to ten
okay iris double
so i'm actually gonna just create a iris
2 really quick okay
so what's kind of useful about set diff
and
i guess union probably set diff is the
most important one
is that say we have you know two data
sets
and we want to basically remove any of
the duplicates between them
uh so you can kind of just do a little
set diff
which is actually we'll yeah we'll just
set diff
and then iris two and then iris
and there's no different oh wait wait
what am i doing
uh iris you know s2
and we can see how um with iris
it basically removed any values that
iris and irs2
shared right uh since irs2 only has 10
and then irs has 150 we know that um
they have the same values
um so we just removed all the same
values from it
but what's more useful probably is the
union function
um and union basically brings in both
similar values
oops um
that they have right union uh
so yeah um let me see here where
[Music]
uh
so these are what are they called
actually set opera observation so
intersect union and set diff oh actually
i totally messed up uh
it's intersect intersect will
uh show uh you know the values are uh
together or shared between two uh data
sets
which is pretty useful and then
union i believe will mean
what's here what is am i doing
um
yeah you will okay it'll keep the values
that they share
okay so with union
let's let's union iris 2
so with iris has 140 549
okay
so it basically removes the the
duplicates that they have between them
okay so i think that's it for
this video i kind of went on a high
level of uh
mutate uh the slicing functions
group by summarize and all that fun
stuff
i i generally think that um one of the
big things with the tidy verse
is basically understanding um how they
get used in a workflow
so a lot of my videos i just kind of use
it as is
and once you get the hang of you know
when you want to do the pivoting
um when you want to mutate when you want
to do your group bias it just makes it
easier to convey a lot of
ideas and analysis that you want to try
because at the end of the day
at the end of the day the tigers is
really just a tool set to use to
extract some type of story or
information from a data set
so um i hope you guys enjoyed this video
um i am planning on making
another one going over uh was it uh
stringer reader and four cats
uh so that'll be pretty fun i'm not
gonna make a gg fought video just
because
most of my videos go over ggpot pretty
uh
quickly um but that might be
an individual video i'm not sure yet and
i'm also planning on doing a
a per video which would go over
functional programming which is
definitely more catered towards an
intermediate audience
so um i'll see you guys next time and
tidy on